empiecen a hacer nuestro trabajo, nosotros ya no tendremos que hacerlo más,
y seremos liberados del trabajo arduo y monotono.
Cuando hablo de esto con mis amigos
en Cambridge y en el Valle de Silicio, me dicen,
"Fantástico. No más monotonía ni trabajos fatigantes.
Esto nos da la oportunidad para imaginar
un tipo de sociedad totalmente diferente,
una sociedad donde las reuniones de creadores e iventores,
de diseñadores y realizadores,
con sus jefes y patrocinadores sean
para conversar, recrearse, compartir ideas,
y provocarse mutuamente".
Es, en verdad, una sociedad que se parece bastante a las conferencias TED.
Y hay mucho de verdad en todo esto.
Estamos presenciando un increíible florecimiento.
En un mundo donde hacer un objeto
es tan fácil como imprimir un documento,
tenemos nuevas y fantásticas posibilidades.
Quienes solían ser iniciados y artesanos
ahora son creadores y son responsables
de gran cantidad de innovación.
Y los artistas, que estaban limitados,
pueden ahora hacer cosas que
antes no podían.
Asi que este es un tiempo de gran florecimiento,
y mientras más veo a mi alrededor, más me convenzo
que la frase del físico Freeman Dyson
no es para nada un hipérbole.
Es simplemente una declaración de los hechos.
Estamos a la mitad de un periodo sorprendente.
[" La tecnología es un regalo de Dios, que después del regalo de la vida, es quizá su más grande regalo, madre de civilizaciones, del arte y la ciencia".]
Lo cual nos plantea otra gran pregunta:
¿Qué podría salir mal en esta nueva era de la máquina?
¿Nada? ¡Fantástico... no se diga más... prosperemos... vámonos a casa!
Vamos a enfrentar dos conjuntos de desafíos realmente espinosos
a medida que nos adentremos en el futuro que estamos creando.
El primero es económico y está realmente bien resumido
en una historia apócrifa de un cruce de sátiras
entre Henry Ford II y Walter Reuther,
quien era el jefe del sindicato de trabajadores automotrices.
Estaban recorriendo una de las nuevas fábricas modernas
y Ford, bromeando, mira a Reuther y le dice,
"Oye Walter, ¿cómo harás para que esos robots
paguen las cuotas sindicales?"
Y Reuther replica,
"¿cómo harás tú Henry, para que compren autos?" —Risas—
El problema de Reuther en esa anécdota
es que es dificil ofrecer la fuerza de trabajo en una economía
que está llena de máquinas,
y lo vemos claramente en las estadísticas.
Si se mira los retornos sobre capital de las dos últimas décadas,
—en otras palabras, las ganancias empresariales—
vemos que suben,
y que están hoy en el punto más alto de todos los tiempos.
Si miramos los rendimientos en mano de obra, en otras palabras
el total de los salarios pagados en la economía,
los vemos en su punto más bajo
y alejándose rápidamente en la dirección opuesta.
Así que estas eran claramente malas noticias para Reuther.
Parece que estas fueran excelentes noticias para Ford,
pero realmente no lo son. Si quieres vender
grandes cantidades de bienes más bien caros a las personas,
querrías entonces contar con una clase media grande, estable y próspera.
Hemos tenido una así en Estados Unidos
durante casi todo el periodo de la posguerra.
Pero la clase media está claramente bajo una gran amenaza hoy en día.
Todos conocemos bien las estadísticas,
pero permítanme recordar una de ellas,
el ingreso promedio en EE UU ha bajado
en estos últimos 15 años,
y estamos en peligro de quedar atrapados
en un círculo vicioso en el que la desigualdad y la polarización
continúan creciendo con el tiempo.
Los desafios sociales que vienen
con ese tipo de desigualdad merecen cierta atención.
Hay un conjunto de desafíos sociales
que en realidad no me preocupan tanto,
y que son capturados por imágenes como estas.
Este no es el tipo de problema social
que me preocupa.
Que no haya disminución de las visiones distópicas
sobre lo que pasará cuando nuestras máquinas se vuelvan auto conscientes
y decidan levantarse y coordinar ataques contra nosotros,
es algo de lo que me empezaré a preocupar
el día en que mi computadora adquiera conciencia de mi impresora.
(Risas) (Aplausos)
Así que esos no son los desafíos por los que debemos preocuparnos.
Para precisar los tipos de desafios sociales
que surgirán con la nueva era de la máquina,
quiero contarles una historia sobre dos trabajadores estadounidenses estereotipo.
Y para que sean realmente estereotipos,
hagamos que ambos sean unos tipos blancos.
El primero es un profesional educado en la universidad,
del tipo creativo... gerente,
ingeniero, doctor, abogado, ese tipo de trabajador.
Vamos a llamarlo "Ted".
Está en la cima de la clase media estadounidense.
Su contraparte no fue educado en la universidad
y trabaja como obrero; trabaja como dependiente.
Hace trabajos de oficina o manuales de bajo nivel en la economía.
Vamos a llamar a esa persona "Bill".
Si retrocedemos unos 50 años,
hallaremos a Bill y a Ted llevando vidas bastante similares.
En 1960, ellos, por ejemplo, muy probablemente tenían
empleos de tiempo completo trabajando por lo menos 40 horas a la semana.
Pero tal y como lo ha documentado el investigador social Charles Murray,
desde que empezamos a automatizar la economía,
y en 1960 las computadoras recién empiezan a ser utilizadas en los negocios,
desde que empezamos a inyectar progresivamente la tecnología,
la automatización y las cosas digitales en la economía,
las vidas de Bill y Ted cambiaron significativamente.
Durante este periodo, Ted ha conservado
su trabajo de tiempo completo. Bill no.
En muchos casos, los Bill han salido por completo de la economía,
mientras que los Ted lo han hecho solo en raros casos.
Al paso del tiempo, Ted ha disfrutado de un feliz matrimonio,
Bill no.
Y los hijos de Ted han crecido en un hogar de dos padres,
mientras que los de Bill no.
¿De qué otras formas los Bill están desapareciendo de nuestra sociedad?
Sus votos en las elecciones presidenciales han disminuido
y han empezado a ir a prision de forma más frecuente.
Asi que no puedo contar una historia feliz sobre estas tendencias sociales
y no se ve ningun indicio de que se revertirán.
Son ciertas independientemente del grupo étnico
o demográfico que miremos,
y se están volviendo tan severas
que existe el riesgo de que opaquen
incluso los increíbles avances que logramos con el Movimiento de los Derechos Civiles.
Y lo que mis amigos del Valle del Silicio
y de Cambridge están pasando por alto es que ellos son Ted.
Ellos estan viviendo estas vidas increíblemente ocupadas y productivas
y tienen todos los beneficios para probarlo,
mientras que Bill lleva una vida bastante diferente.
Ambos son prueba de lo acertado que estaba Voltaire
cuando hablaba sobre los beneficios del trabajo,
y del hecho de que este nos salva no de uno, si no de 3 grandes males.
["El trabajo salva al hombre de tres grandes males: el aburrimiento, el vicio y la necesidad". - Voltaire]
Asi que, ¿qué hacemos con estos desafíos?
El manual de economía es sorprendentemente claro,
sorprendentemente directo, especialmente a corto plazo.
Los robots no se quedarán con todos nuestros trabajos el próximo año o el siguiente,
así que el manual básico de economía nos servirá:
Fomentar el espíritu empresarial,
reducir a la mitad la infraestructura,
y asegurarnos de que estamos sacando a las personas
de nuestro sistema educativo con las habilidades apropiadas.
Pero a largo plazo, si nos estamos moviendo hacia una economía
que esta llena de tecnología pero baja en trabajo,
y lo estamos haciendo, entonces tenemos que considerar
algunas intervenciones más radicales.
Por ejemplo, algo como un ingreso mínimo garantizado.
Esto probablemente incomode a algunas personas en este recinto,
porque esta idea está asociada con la extrema izquierda
y con esquemas bastante radicales para la distribución de las riquezas.
He hecho un poco de investigación al respecto,
y tal vez tranquilice a algunos saber que
la idea de un ingreso mínimo neto garantizado
ha sido defendida por rabiosos socialistas como
Friedrich Hayeck, Richard Nixon y Milton Friedman.
Y si les preocupa
que algo como el ingreso garantizado
vaya a sofocar nuestra motivación por el éxito
y nos vuelva algo complacientes,
tal vez esten interesados en saber que la movilización social,
una de las cosas de las que realmente nos enorgullecemos en los Estados Unidos,
es ahora menor que en los países al norte de Europa,
que tienen redes de seguridad social bastante generosas.
El manual económico, entonces, es en verdad bastante preciso;
el social es bastante más desafiante.
No sé cuál es el manual
para hacer que Bill se emplee y se mantenga empleado durante su vida.
Lo que sí se es que la educacíon es una gran parte de ese proceso.
Soy testigo de primera mano de eso.
Fui un niño Montessori durante los primeros años de mi educación,
y lo que esa educación me enseñó
es que el mundo es un lugar interesante
y que mi trabajo es salir a explorarlo.
El colegio se acabó cuando estaba en tercer grado,
y entonces entré al sistema de educación pública,
y se sentía como si hubiera sido enviado al gulag.
Con el beneficio de la retrospectiva, ahora sé que trataban
de prepararme para la vida como dependiente o obrero,
pero al mismo tiempo sentí que trataban como
de aburrirme y de que cayera en una sumisión con lo que sucedía a mi alrededor.
Tenemos que hacerlo mejor que esto.
No podemos seguir terminando como Bills.
Vemos algunos retoños de cosas que mejoran.
Vemos a la tecnología impactando profundamente en la educación
y empleando personas, desde nuestros más jovenes aprendices
hasta los más viejos.
Vemos voces de negocios bastante prominentes diciéndonos que
necesitamos replantear algunas de las cosas que hemos estado estimado por mucho tiempo.
Y vemos esfuerzos bastante serios y sostenidos,
e informados, por entender
cómo intervenir en algunas de las comunidades con más problemas que tenemos.
Entonces, los retoños estan ahí.
No pretendo que se entienda
que lo que tenemos es suficiente.
Estamos frente a desafíos bastante difíciles.
Para dar solo un ejemplo, hay cerca de 5 millones de estadounidenses
que han estado desempleados por al menos 6 meses.
No vamos a arreglar las cosas para ellos
mandándolos de regreso a Montesssori.
Mi mayor preocupación es que estemos creando un mundo
donde tengamos tecnologías deslumbrantes
incrustradas en una especie de sociedad desgastada
y respaldada por una economía que genera desigualdad
en lugar de oportunidad.
Pero en realidad no creo que hagamos eso.
Creo que haremos algo mucho mejor
por una muy simple razón:
Los hechos estan siendo expuestos.
Las realidades de esta nueva era de la máquina
y el cambio en la economía están siendo ampliamente conocidos.
Si quisieramos acelerar el proceso, podríamos hacer cosas
como hacer que nuestros mejores economistas y políticos
jueguen "¡Jeopardy!" contra Watson.
Podríamos mandar al Congreso de viaje en un carro autónomo.
Y si hacemos suficientes cosas de este tipo,
se terminará por entender que las cosas van a ser diferentes.
Y entonces estaremos listos para la pelea,
porque no creo ni por un segundo
que hayamos olvidado cómo resolver los desafíos dificiles
o que nos hayamos vuelto tan apáticos o duros de corazón como para no intentarlo.
Empecé mi charla con frases de oradores
que estaban separados por un océano y un siglo,
déjenme terminarla con palabras de políticos
que estaban igualmente distantes.
Winston Churchill fue a mi casa del MIT en 1949,
y dijo, "Si vamos a llevar al grueso de las personas
de todas las latitudes a la mesa de la abundancia,
esto será solo mediante mejoras incansables
de todos nuestros medios de producción técnica".
Abraham Lincoln se percató de que había otro ingrediente.
Dijo, " Soy un firme creyente en las personas.
Si se les dice la verdad, se podrá contar con ellas
para enfrentar cualquier crisis nacional.
El secreto está en darles los hechos escuetos".
Asi que la nota optimista, el gran secreto con el que quiero dejarlos
es que los hechos tajantes de la nueva era de la máquina se estan volviendo claros,
y que confío plenamente en que los usaremos
para trazar un buen curso para la desafiante,
y abundante economía que estamos creando.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)